Terri's gonna die saving the President
or Terry's never gonna die being scary
Terry he says what breaking uh Terry's
thinking Terry needs nutrients Terry
won't do you like that
I'm not EDA daddy whoa Nyong'o no being
killed Nikita
shits our docket Minooka Terry believes
in having a clear topic sentence little
Terry loved the hustle Terry loves
kreplach I can't wait
this weekend I am vacation Terry don't
know why I didn't go undercover as
someone wearing a scarf Terry hates
windchill good use it little Terry wrote
his own story yeah a little Terry got
buff Oh Terry got emotionally healthy
yeah and dragged you know what didn't
get Jack
way to go little Terry Terry is back Oh
chop
diaper Oh what vacation Terry is dead
the bank of Terry is closed do it for
love damn Jake you know Terry loves love
very bar food doughnut did you tell him
Terry doesn't love walls no Terry loves
walls Terry loves lavender oh great job
kids don't solve too many crimes to put
me out of business
Terry's got to pay the rent look Terry
loves love but Terry also loves
maintaining a professional work
environment it's horrifying from
everywhere Terry hates creepy crawlers
Terry loves responsible agricultural
practices you all better get ready for
fun Terry no fun Terry sounds fun
no he's crazy Terry hates bathroom talk
damn it Terry proved the wrong point
this is totally how I thought this Miss
Marian thing was gonna go another
flawless Terry plan
yeah Terry Jeffords makes big babies I
did graduate magna [ __ ] laude from
Syracuse I know that sounds like a brag
and it was Terry killed it in college
Terry cause structural damage my god
you're strong Gary needs reading glasses
you came to toppdogg Terry
smart move I've been solving problems
all day long
oh you guys have an extra mouse from a
computer no but hey here you can borrow
mine Terry knows his keyboard shortcuts
just deleted everything feels like a
[ __ ]
but eating a big drumstick on
Thanksgiving makes Terry feel like a
king
whoa little cherry did not see that
coming I mean Terry's our boss and he
comes with us every year correction you
bring vacation Terry and he is no man's
boss when the slippers are filled Terry
Terry did not see that coming I get that
the streets are empty but slow down man
Terry forgot his family Oh Terry hates
hospitals they week of death
Terry was hot Terry was not a problem
for Terry Terry does not have a problem
at all
Terry's got a big problem Terry feels
baha'i Terry still gets after that's all
I'm saying she's gonna lose unless her
talent is leaving potato chip crumbs all
over Terry's couch fun Terry's gone he
starved to death an hour ago this is
original Terry that's the worst Harry
top dog Terry can make a decision and
what would that be this top dog Terry
want a moment to think about it Terry
heard of crinkle hold her to crinkle too
you could use some decent shoes what
Terry got these an aldose no it wasn't
it was a three for one Labor Day
doorbuster this better be an emergency
there better be a gun to your head
Charles Gina and I are in a hostage
situation oh god I shouldn't said the
gun thing Terry regrets the way he
answered the phone
Terry need to be in Terry is embracing
his age
Terry crushed it it works
Terry loved Tommy Tommy turned Terry on
to tennis fun Terry's batting no wife no
kids just Terry Starr fishing on a cow
cherry can't own anything the point is
something I'll told it Terry
is your God all hail Lord Terry giver of
life oh the show leaves Terry one more
dunk oh god Terry walk who do i theta no
no I love Elizabeth moss Jerry thought
the show was too bleep Terry was too
cold to consummate Terry's got buck but
Dave excuse me
I said Terry's got but four days please
stop talking about my body what I'm
Terry you just said I had but four days
mm-hmm
I see what you said man Terry's gonna
regret this Terry can't throw his family
away but these are nice suspenders Jerry
needs a safe space to process his
emotions no he's right Terry out of tone
Terry had a big time tone
Terry needs to earn that fees just
because mine a crappy RV doesn't mean I
still can't be first-class Terry Terry
loves to be loved
oh my kidding Terry Terry tried 10 toys
stores Terry sick of shiver take the
damn car Terry doesn't deserve Terry
hates Birds
Terry can do yoga Terry is a yoga Beast
watch you mean you're gonna do well
we're in warrior pose now but I suppose
for you we can start in child's pose
Siri is not a child
Siri is a warrior Terry doesn't order
books online
he supports local bookstores they're
dying Amy what was all this
it's just Gary being Terry yeah Terry's
not enough of this 7 year old Terry can
eat whatever he wants Terry tear it up I
love when calamity brings people
together he needs a bulkier play it
oh no Terry can't move Terry needs help
ah Terry's husband game is flawless
Terry never loses his key Terry knows
tomorrow's not promised ok then let's
start with your blood pressure no we can
skip this part always clocked in at 130
over 80
Terry's in tip-top please Diaz top dog
Terry does not need to look for captain
hosts manual
he knows it's on his computer top dog
Terry he was looking for the passport
Terry hates bugs too many eyes and legs
told you Andrew
Terri's in tip-top Amy I knew I ruined
your bear but I made you a new one
it's a shower curtain yep Terry fumble
two ties stop saying my passwords
hey I'm Gina Terry's got an update his
keychain I hope it ends soon
Terry shoulders run built for tight
spaces it's bunk City in here Terry
hates tests
Terry's never had Austrian yoga before
Terry had the best moment of all rather
than the way what the hell I wrote notes
in the margin Terry found it super
objective oh man Terry forgot about his
nose Boyle something wrong with Terry's
chin I want to get involved oh god it's
true he's worried about his tests and
his bow I bet you're excited about the
raise that comes with your promotion
well Terry doesn't like to talk about
money but up chi-ching this might not be
the right time but talking about
yourself in the third person has finally
carreño
you